it might not look like it but these
people are providing a vital service
[Music]
without any external funding anya and
her friends deliver groceries and basic
goods to some of the most vulnerable in
kiev
some of the goods are donated but most
are paid for by the volunteers
themselves
i always wanted to do humanitarian work
i don't have grandparents so this helps
me compensate for that it really comes
from my heart
maria rarely leaves the house she's too
frail to make the journey and the
elevator in her building is best
described as temperamental
she stayed in the city because she says
she has no family to go to without the
volunteers she'll be completely alone
and hungry
i was in hospital with heart problems
and my daughter died recently
i have a niece who could help but public
transport is shut so she can't get here
right now i don't need anything because
they brought me things but this won't
last long
the volunteers work under the umbrella
of an organization called love life
which existed before the war to help the
homeless and vulnerable
now it's one of the only organizations
of its kind in ukraine still operating
and demand for its services far
outstrips its capacity
to cope the organization has changed the
way it operates it identifies the most
vulnerable people and posts them on a
private social media channel
volunteers then make the deliveries
navigating the city's many checkpoints
and anti-tank barricades
and it's not just home delivery
kitchens and roadside kiosks have also
become a front line of sorts in the war
effort
most of the restaurants across the city
are shut but the kitchens are open and
the chefs are working now they might not
be making their usual cuisines what
they're doing is they're making
home-style cuisines that then volunteers
pick up and bring to distribution points
like these and it is a lifeline for many
this might be the one hot meal that they
get a day imran khan al jazeera kiev